so it's Christian up 3 8 ^ 0 now we've
got down there 3 agreement yes yes okay
excellent now if you saw that what do
you think will be the most common for
this given that's not 3 1 D 1 what is
the most common our time that's given
apart from 3 now that's a really easy
mistake to make what this take is being
mean what would make that question how
can we change it to maybe a 2-1 what
could we do yes not ok very good
this is something we're going to see
quite a few times as we go through these
questions if there are brackets that
means that Libre pal applies to
everything in time right so the 3 gets a
power 0 the a gets power 0 and they were
both become one but C is the question
but here you got how brackets all right
that power is 0 that power 0 doesn't
have anything to do with the 3 so this
really is 3 times 1 which is 3 okay so
what could good for the 1 number 2
number 2 what do you think look okay can
someone tell me hands up what had to be
done with the power is over here to get
the powers over here what's the actual
more give you that you've added the
powers because you are multiplying
numbers with the save 100 a second
I think reminds us before but you've
heard this word before these numbers up
here are powers what are these others
the ones on the bottom starts with a big
it's the base right so if the bases are
the same you can add the past that's
right
yet I'll just wait till I have
everyone's attention and then we can
keep going
number three is sort of the reverse of
number one is it because it does have
records that mean it's not just feet
maybe get cubes the six also get shoes
is 216 correct or not
yeah 636 to two things having a look up
here you've got some canceling the habit
that will help you remember what's going
on
remember in ^ 5 it's just an
abbreviation
what is it abbreviation all incidental
them touch em touch em right five of
them so therefore if you actually write
what it is and you go to step 4
okay you can see here the canceling is
really busy right just like with Dom
lovers - on the bottom means you lose
two of the top which means you have
three four I'm the encoder you probably
write it like this even though there's
the derivative what we did it's a bit
weird to see decimals mixed in with
indices like that it's not you don't
never see it but let's call it so damn
straight
alright now before we talk about whether
this answer is right or wrong
has anyone got a different answer to
this it almost a big different written
down so what did you have do anyone has
anything different to that so another
look at these two which is that up there
kids would be right you can't ask to
simplify this is a really important
thing I've said this a few times before
I'm gonna beat the drum again because
you need really to get it for your 11 to
12 the word simplified means make it
simple off okay now let's just think
about this in simple terms simple touch
in straightforward terms if you speak
English then English is a simple
language for you to understand if you
speak Turkish the Turkish is simpler
language for you to understand the web
simplified means different
things in different contexts now see you
don't have any context there's nothing
that tells you actually a negative index
is sometimes better no negative this is
writing everything as fractions rather
than negative indices is sometimes
better I was going to give a big kick to
both of these however usually usually I
like to provide answers in before that
the question has been given if the
question has fractions
I'll give the answer back as a fraction
if the question has negative indices
I'll give the answer back with negative
indices unless the question specifies
you guys are see in 501 sometimes it
says right blah blah blah without
negative issues in which case this
should be given an acceptable answer
gonnigan
okay and the last one I'm just looking
at that quickly now looks good right
yeah do that yes Thanks